[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí a América este es
el magacín de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
al menos 50 muertos dejan las protestas
en Perú se trata de Seguidores del
expresidente Pedro Castillo que se han
enfrentado a la policía antidisturbios
una delegación de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos viajó
al país para verificar la situación en
la que tanto ciudadanos como uniformados
han fallecido y vamos a hablar también
de Brasil donde seguidores de Jair
bolsonaro asaltaron las sedes de los
tres poderes en Brasilia suena familiar
les mostramos las similitudes con el
asalto al Capitolio por parte de
Seguidores de Donald Trump en 2021
y visitaremos Ciudad de México donde se
reunieron los jefes de estado y de
gobierno de los tres países de
Norteamérica la Cumbre de los Tree
amigos reconcilió a México con Estados
Unidos y logró acuerdos entre Canadá la
Unión Americana y México en materia de
economía migración y lucha contra las
drogas después del boicot que Andrés
Manuel López Obrador le hizo a la Cumbre
de las Américas en Los Ángeles en junio
de 2022 hace 7 meses
nuestra historia principal está en Perú
que sigue encendido en protestas
especialmente en el sur del país cerca
de la frontera con Bolivia donde esta
semana se registró el día más mortífero
desde que iniciaron las manifestaciones
en diciembre con 18 víctimas mortales en
enfrentamientos entre los policías
antidisturbios y los manifestantes ya
son casi 50 muertos en estas
circunstancias el epicentro de los
choques está en la localidad de juliaca
pero también se vivieron en cusco la
puerta de entrada al turístico Machu
Picchu donde están las emblemáticas
ruinas incas
[Música]
estas protestas empezaron en diciembre
tras una convulsa jornada en la que el
entonces presidente Pedro Castillo
intentó disolver el congreso que iba a
reunirse a votar su destitución por
señalamientos de corrupción en su contra
Castillo Fue entonces retirado del cargo
por rebelión además de su Liberación
desde entonces los manifestantes piden
la renuncia de la presidenta Dina
boluarte quien asumió el poder una vez
salió castillo y ya su gabinete descartó
una dimisión también piden que se
disuelva el congreso elecciones
anticipadas que ya fueron movidas de
2026 a abril de 2024 y ahora le suman
por supuesto el reclamo por justicia
para los fallecidos en medio de estos
choques entre policías antidisturbios y
manifestantes
el congreso por su parte aprobó la
creación de una comisión especial que va
a investigar estas muertes Asimismo
llegó una delegación de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos que
Investiga las violaciones a los derechos
fundamentales en el marco de estas
manifestaciones pero escuchemos a las
personas que protestan las banderas
negras de nuestro pueblo significan de
que el gobierno este usurpador ha
asesinado al pueblo y empezaron a
disparar a quemarropa a quien sea que
pase el jovencito que ha muerto no era
un protestante él estaba pasando se ha
asomado y es vecino él se ha asomado
nada más Y de frente le ha caído el el
arma de fuego le ha caído acá señora
Dina boluarte dese cuenta que la están
utilizando Por qué ustedes está dando la
espalda al pueblo son tantas muertes por
Dios paren con toda esta masacre no es
justo Yo sé que la gente que está
saliendo a protestar es gente que está
indignada como yo y no nos está que no
somos terrucos en medio de los
disturbios autoridades peruanas
prohibieron el ingreso al país del
expresidente boliviano Evo Morales a
quien acusan de intervenir en los
asuntos políticos del país vamos a
hablar con nuestro corresponsal en Lima
Francisco Zacarías quien se encuentra en
camino hacia el sur del Perú y nos
explica la coyuntura de esta región
epicentro de las protestas y que es
fronteriza con Bolivia
puno y su principal ciudad juliaca son
el corazón de las protestas en el sur
del Perú con 67 mil kilómetros cuadrados
es la quinta región más extensa del país
cuenta con más de un millón
cuatrocientos mil habitantes Allí se
ubica el lago titicaca el más alto del
mundo Según la leyenda del origen del
imperio de los incas desde el titicaca
emergió una pareja manco cápac y mama
occhio quienes recibieron la misión del
dios inti de encontrar un lugar donde
fundar el incanato la población es su
mayoría es indígena ellos se comunican
en quechua aymara y español su principal
actividad es la agricultura pero el
territorio también vive del comercio y
la minería uno limita por el este con
Bolivia y esto según las autoridades
peruanas sería aprovechado por el
expresidente boliviano Evo Morales para
alentar las protestas en esa región
dentro de un operativo que buscaría
desintegrar el sur peruano y crear un
nuevo país que sería denominado nación
aymara las autoridades no Solo han
prohibido el ingreso de Evo al Perú la
fiscalía ha admitido una denuncia penal
contra el ex mandatario boliviano por el
delito de separatismo la acusación ha
sido sustentada por el congresista Jorge
Montoya quien afirmó que el Ministerio
Público se encuentre elaborando la
resolución que detalla el inicio de la
investigación que se estará iniciando en
los próximos días las indagaciones se
ampliará contra ocho ciudadanos
bolivianos quienes también están
impedidos ingresar al Perú por otro lado
la denuncia además de Morales implica
Vladimir cerrón Aliado del expresidente
Pedro castillo y al ex gobernador de
puno Germán Alejo por los delitos de
atentado contra la seguridad nacional y
tradición a la patria
Y es que Precisamente en Bolivia también
hay protestas específicamente en la
provincia de Santa Cruz de la Sierra
allí los manifestantes exigen la
liberación de Luis Fernando Camacho el
gobernador opositor que fue detenido
acusado de terrorismo en el marco del
proceso de la crisis de 2019 cuando
justamente Evo Morales fue obligado a
renunciar tras perder el apoyo del
ejército por postularse a la reelección
a pesar de que había perdido un
referendo en el que los bolivianos
dijeron que no podía aspirar nuevamente
al cargo
y nos vamos a Brasil que también vive
días convulsos seguidores de Jair
bolsonaro asaltaron las sedes de los
tres poderes en Brasilia los
bolsonaristas invadieron el congreso la
presidencia y el tribunal supremo de
Justicia para pedir una intervención
militar y la renuncia de Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva Quien ganó las elecciones
presidenciales de octubre y asumió el
poder el primero de enero la custodia de
la ciudad estaba en manos de la policía
militar por lo que el presidente anunció
una purga dentro de esta institución que
anunció colaboró con los asaltantes
escuchemos sus palabras
es importante decir que hubo muchos
Cómplices entre la Policía Militar hubo
muchas personas de las fuerzas armadas
que fueron Cómplices estoy convencido de
que la puerta del palacio se abrió para
permitir la entrada de estas personas
porque no vi que la puerta estuviera
rota es decir significa que alguien
facilitó su entrada vamos a investigar a
ver qué ha pasado
y vio que aconteció mi verdad las
imágenes de Brasil son impactantes pero
algunos podemos hallar la similitud con
otras que ya hemos visto anteriormente
durante la toma del Capitolio en
Washington el 6 de enero de 2021 además
de las fechas similares hay varias
coincidencias como los dos expresidentes
que no reconocieron sus derrotas
electorales veamos el informe de Luis
Muñoz
en la izquierda Brasilia y en la derecha
Washington son dos imágenes que pasarán
a la historia similares en forma y fondo
siendo el primer evento de la actualidad
internacional de su respectivo año
Brasil 2023 la toma de los edificios del
poder judicial legislativo y ejecutivo
mientras que Estados Unidos en 2021 y la
toma del Capitolio en los dos países dos
líderes de extrema derecha derrotados
con simpatía mutua de hecho el
expresidente de Brasil Jair bolsonaro
apoyó a los manifestantes de Washington
y hasta tuvo un emisario allí lo analizó
en France 24 Darío piñotti el que está
encargado de Los vínculos
Internacionales Eduardo bolsonaro siguió
defendiendo hasta último momento no solo
que no se conociera la victoria de Lula
sino que se hiciera algo parecido a lo
que ocurrió en el Capitolio por lo demás
Eduardo bolsonaro estuvo en Washington
antes de los sucesos arengas de los dos
mandatarios y rechazo público del
resultado electoral
los movimientos populares actuales son
el resultado de la indignación y un
sentimiento de injusticia sobre cómo se
llevó a cabo el proceso electoral
[Aplausos]
para usar un término que a todos ustedes
les guste detendremos el robo
ni Trump ni bolsonaro acudieron a la
proclamación presidencial de sus rivales
electorales y después de las tomas de
los manifestantes si bien tramo optó por
el silencio bolsonaro hizo una tímida
condena en Twitter esto mientras sonaba
el ruido de la condena de la comunidad
internacional en Estados Unidos se
suceden Las investigaciones y juicios
con el expresidente Donald Trump en el
centro en Brasil ya se anunciaron
pesquisas también con el ex presidente
Jair bolsonaro señalado la justicia
tendrá la última palabra
y vamos a México para revisar la imagen
de la semana Los jefes de estado y de
gobierno de los países de Norteamérica
se reunieron en la Cumbre de los Tree
amigos el Primer Ministro de Canadá
Justin trudeo el presidente
estadounidense Joe biden y el mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador anunciaron
acuerdos en tres asuntos cruciales para
sus relaciones Estos son la migración
donde anunciaron el lanzamiento de una
plataforma digital donde los migrantes
antes de iniciar la travesía hacia el
norte deberán primero averiguar si
califican para un programa disponible
postularse y recibir una autorización de
viaje si no lo hacen serán expulsados de
manera inmediata de cualquiera de los
tres países en cuanto a economía crearán
un equipo de trabajo para estudiar la
sustitución de las importaciones desde
Asia mientras que en materia de lucha
contra el narcotráfico amlo prometió que
atajara el tráfico de fentanilo la mayor
causa de muerte por sobredosis en
Estados Unidos con más de 100,000
fallecimientos en 2022
pero en Washington los anuncios del
presidente estadounidense no llamaron
tanto la atención debido a que se
conoció que se hallaron documentos
clasificados tanto en la oficina de Joe
biden en Delaware como en su despacho de
la capital estadounidense de cuando era
el vicepresidente de Barack Obama el
fiscal general de la Unión Americana
Mary Garland designó a un fiscal
independiente para investigar el caso lo
que generó críticas de los republicanos
por la forma en la que fue manejado un
caso similar de documentos clasificados
en la residencia de mar lago en Florida
del ex presidente Donald Trump Pero hay
diferencias entre los casos miren en el
caso de Trump se hallaron 325 archivos
clasificados y en el de biden alrededor
de una decena además en el caso de Trump
fueron hallados en su residencia Privada
de Mara lago ya lo decíamos mientras que
en el de biden en sus oficinas lugares
de trabajo Trump los funcionarios de los
archivos nacionales iniciaron un
contacto con su oficina después de
determinar que no tenían algunos
documentos destacados de su mandato Como
por ejemplo la correspondencia con el
presidente de Corea del Norte Kim
jong-un al no obtener colaboración fue
que allanaron su residencia Mientras que
el equipo de biden los entregó
voluntariamente hasta aquí esta emisión
de aquí América gracias por acompañarme
en la primera de 2023 por favor envíenme
sus comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Giovanni agudelo
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web France 24.com y
Para más información de nuestro
continente Sigan viendo France 24
[Música]